here with reaction Tennessee senator
Marcia Blackburn Senator Blackburn thank
you for being here with us on a Friday
night you know a axios is saying
Democrats in the Senate think this is a
nightmare are you hearing that on the
hill everyone has expected that that Joe
Mansion would make that decision to not
run for reelection and Kaylee I think
what this points out is Democrats know
that people are not responding to their
message when it comes to our national
security inflation the Border crime in
the streets and they know this is going
to be a tough year for them so West
Virginia looks good for us but we have
to make certain that we hold what we
have and that we pick up those seats and
I'm one of those incumbents that is
going to be running next year so Marsha
Blackburn Doom I'm certainly working
hard on my race to make certain that I
win and that we do take the Senate and
that we have President Trump back in the
white house and we take nothing for
granted to your point I mean what do you
say to Republican voters right I mean
2022 wasn't a red wave 2023 these
elections weren't great on Tuesday what
do you say to voters who say this all
looks good but we're
worried and I hope that that pushes them
to get active in 2024 we cannot have
freedom loving Patriots sitting on the
sideline and people know that preserving
our freedoms preserving our rights
preserving that
Constitution recognizing that we're a
nation of laws and that we abide by the
rule of law all of that is going to be
important and these races in 2024 will
determine what road we're going to
travel when I talk to tennesseans they
are all about making certain that we
retain the the America that they have
known where everyone has an opportunity
to live out their version of the
American dream Senator Blackburn it's
hard to believe you've been there six
years um you done a great job thank you
very much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else